hopefully something's happening now
uh good to be here
my name is hans
maybe i should put my glasses back on i
just don't like that you can see the
ring light
in the glasses
getting a lot of text messages that
aren't from joe rogan
i need an inside man to tell me who's
opening for rogan so i could be jealous
in a more directed way
um
i don't know what's happening
so
anyone seeing any of this
china
let's see what's going on
i think it's live now
i think we just switched let's see
what's going on
okay i think i think everything's fine
now
um
so i think that um
i don't know
yeah i mean i obviously
don't want to
be filled with jealousy
uh but i kind of want to know who's
opening for him i think asana mod [ __ ] i
think he's very funny
and i would love to
you know
go back to back with
him but unfortunately i don't think
that's happening
um
so funny story i was uh performing on
new year's with asana mod and then after
the show we're just hanging out it's new
year's it's a weird kind of show
and then uh
and then uh
some guy some random guy goes up to
assange like i thought you were the best
on the show man the way that you did
your act outs and the [ __ ]
you combined it all it was really really
good man and i was like right there
listening to this
and uh i was fuming
and then uh he started asking the
stupidest questions like how long have
you been doing this
oh yeah i think i could do it too like
if i really wanted to do it i think i'd
be pretty good at it
it's that kind of vibe and then i stood
up to get out of there and then he came
up to me and i was like hey man oh i
thought you did really good i was like
yeah whatever
oh whatever and then i walked away
it's like why do you think your opinion
on the comedy matters so much like
you're the arbiter like oh i get to
decide who's good and who's bad
um and also like if i think you're good
then i need to tell you because it's
such a big deal that i thought you were
good that you need to hear that you were
successful
because now you've made it you've earned
my respect and opinion it's like just
keep that [ __ ] to yourself especially if
it's like if the other person is right
next to you then it's like
yeah you don't want to say that
in front of another person because
that'll hurt their feelings so maybe
just be aware of who's around you when
you're giving
uh superlative compliments
um
it's just uh
it's just like uh artists are sensitive
we're showing ourselves up there
uh
and it's just like when uh
when when you say that
i went up there and i tried my best and
shown myself and was vulnerable and
exposed my soul and then you're like oh
i thought the other guy was exposing his
soul better
uh i like the way that uh he did it but
the way that you were like being
vulnerable and like telling us all your
deepest secrets i wasn't really a fan of
that i liked the way that the other guy
did it
it's like uh yeah i mean we should have
that because then you get better if you
like try to be better but it's just like
you should uh you shouldn't uh you know
do that you shouldn't
compare people in front of them
um but yeah i mean i've been at the
other end of that compliment exchange
where they're like i thought you were
the best on the show but it's like i
don't know
what that means
i don't know how you think that like
i've been on shows where i was clearly
not the best person and people said it
and i just think like most people that
watch comedy have no idea what's going
on
and they're just feeling and i respect
that they feel that way that they really
enjoy the show
but these comics are clearly better than
me and they've held the crowd for an
hour and if i was to do that
it would suck so hard so like obviously
you're wrong but maybe i'm good in like
a short little bit
uh and i can hit hard it's like a
[ __ ] you know
whatever it's like a little cheating
like a affair versus like a long-term
relationship
but yeah whatever
i i obviously i'm not that good at uh
comedy as a headliner
but yeah i mean it's just it's just
interesting what people
think to say to you
and uh i mean to them it's true so it's
like wow this is like a very truthful
thing that i'm saying and like really
you hit me hard and like i want you to
feel that the way that i hit you or
whatever
honestly like
william was
so funny i don't i remember that night
um i met that guy in the bathroom before
he got called up and he was weird
uh he was like i was like good luck man
you're gonna do great and i was like
thanks man
and he was just like he was just staring
at me like trying to make it weird and
it's like
it was just weird he was he wasn't like
ready to have a good time he was he
wanted to make it he wanted to control
it he wanted to control the moment in
the situation
even if it was bad and awkward and it's
like you shouldn't try to control it
control should be a tool you use to make
the moment better control shouldn't be
your goal and i think his goal was to
control
uh the moment
and i think that's
that's flawed
you shouldn't try to control control as
just a whatever
control is a
a tool
that you use
to
to implement goodness in the world the
goodness that you have to let it shine
you shouldn't just be trying to control
some people have better souls
well the good thing is that you can work
on your soul and uh you shouldn't uh
you shouldn't [ __ ]
you shouldn't uh
work in a cubicle and destroy your soul
maximus
apparently people are really up in arms
about maximus it's funny what people uh
latch on to because when i saw it i was
like oh that's kind of weird and it was
sort of a big deal but i mean there's
like a lot of great stuff and a lot of
funny comics that i had that were on the
show and then like this guy stands out
for
some reason and catches everyone's
attention hans is covered getting bad in
texas you think you're gonna start
cutting the show back again
cutting the show back
what do you mean you think they're gonna
start cutting the show back
unless one of them catches it now and i
don't think
texas really gives a [ __ ] about
coronavirus
unfortunately
i would like to take it seriously and
you know shelter in place
and limit swapping of air but if we're
not doing it then the only reason i
would stop doing is if i'm afraid
personally i'm getting covered in a
situation where everyone's out so
i'm not that afraid of getting covet i
know i'll be fine the only reason our
quarantine is for the good of the
society around me
and since uh no one is doing that since
no one is caring about each other i mean
what am i gonna care about you guys and
alone that's lonely
i'd rather not care about you guys
together with you guys so i can
commiserate and how we don't care about
each other
um i'm sure he was funny but you know
it's just like
i feel like you
need to build the funniness on a good
foundation
and building a funniness on stealing
from others and trying to control the
moment instead of making it a good
moment for everyone involved i don't
think is a good foundation uh and that
means you're not gonna be funny for as
long because people are gonna get tired
of you and all that
um
not getting late as gay as [ __ ] what if
you're getting laid with gay dudes then
is that gay as [ __ ] as well getting late
as gay as [ __ ] and not getting latest
gay as [ __ ] you're in a fork of being
gay no matter
what you do sexually
um
as i did died co-worker who caught it
same time as i did died oh poor guy
coveted sucked had it last week just
horrible yeah it's a new disease it
feels like a new disease it feels like
being car sick it's like oh this is
different
this is like uh the tick tock of
diseases
this is the ariana grande
compared to all the old diseases like
you know
uh
dolly parton
and
betty white
and marilyn
monroe
it's like that's the old disease this is
the new sexy disease again
it's learned from the other disease and
it's better than ever
oh and then they started going on stage
again but with no audience that was dope
they talked so much [ __ ] about those
quarantine episodes but those were some
of my favorite episodes it was really
fun because i needed it at that moment i
needed someone live saying [ __ ]
because no one else's life and that was
when we had like 200 cases when the
whole country shut down and now we have
the highest coven numbers we've ever had
and everything's open at least here in
texas
what's your favorite part of your day
when i
finish my show and do a lot of drugs
i was sad for three years over my ex but
finally found a new piece of strange
that's so crazy that a breakup can be
that devastating
i don't know if we're supposed to break
up with people i think that uh
if breakups are that traumatic like and
[ __ ] up your life that much then what
is that why do we have that
um
i think it's because nature wants us to
stick with one person forever and just
stay with them
um
and i also think that we're meant to be
in smaller groups so that even if you
break up with someone it's traumatic and
it's
chaotic you're still going to see them
every now and then and then you're going
to develop past that wound but since we
live in a society of millions of people
you have a chaotic traumatic moment and
then they just disappear into the ether
and
then you never get to heal that wound
and that wound festers
so i think that
it's better to
solve the issue
and
in a smaller tribal society
hippies were right we should share
everything money drugs [ __ ] i mean
to it to an extent
and this [ __ ] wants to tell me how the
country should be run
my father fought in world war ii
and this [ __ ] wants to tell me how this
country should be run well are you not
going to listen to me just because i'm a
[ __ ] what if i have all the right
answers what if i'm like a master at sim
city and you're like nope not going to
listen to you because you're a [ __ ]
like why don't you just listen to advice
if it's good and not if it's bad i mean
what's your favorite racist joke
so what's the difference between a bike
and a black person a bike doesn't sing
what is chained up
that's pretty basic i don't know if
everyone will appreciate it but that's a
joke
what the hell are you talking about kim
hopefully i can get tickets
yeah dude if you know what time you're
one day you're coming just check on the
website and [ __ ]
buy the ticket
um
it was a joke no worries oh
yeah i did i wasn't really taking
youtube comments seriously
um what the hell
what's your favorite racist check kim
city
but yeah i mean i love uh running cities
and uh figuring it out
i don't think that uh
i don't think we need one person to run
cities
i think maybe we can vote on the city
planner that we agree with the most or
whatever
um
um
but yeah i mean uh
we shouldn't like have a vote to like
how to fix your mom's gallbladder issue
we should be like we want a doctor
that's good at it and maybe we could
have like a vote for like oh who's the
best general or the military commander
i think this guy is or like have like a
more industry-wide vote like what kind
of plumbing do we need for the city and
then like all the plumbers vote
um
but i think radical democracy is the way
to go that prevents one person from
gaining power and becoming a dictator
and only making decisions for their
benefit if we all make the decision
uh then it is better because um
then we all do
the best thing for
ourselves
instead of just for one person our
incentive is to do the best for all of
us not just for one of us
is anyone vetting you to cover up your
eye and make comedy for the deep state
i don't know what that means
um do i like katan sesh
show people how it's played
um
um maybe i should have like uh
did they still do amazon affiliate links
my neck isn't feeling better i'm
thinking of putting on the
neck pillow again
i've grown on david
thanks for letting me grow on you
um
[Music]
i don't think we should give plumbers a
blank check i think we should uh budget
and like give them enough money to do
whatever they need to do oh i cut my own
hair check out the back
i kind of [ __ ] it up
if someone wants to fix that for me
i'm gonna check the
the video because i can't really see it
that well
you don't think i played soccer i'm all
right at soccer i played soccer in high
school
for the high school team
i think soccer is fun soccer soccer's
good it's all about footwork your
footwork has to be so good because not
only do you have to run like basketball
but then you have to like
move the ball with your feet so it's
like if uh
yeah you have to do footwork
to move the ball like in basketball you
just have to do footwork to get to where
you're going
and then your hands do the rest but in
soccer your feet are doing what your
hands
and your feet are doing in basketball so
it's just two jobs at one
it looks great dearly
that's going to be the new style is
having like a jacket back line
on the back of your
neck
to show that you're one of the chat boys
it looks like [ __ ]
so we're gonna build a bureaucracy to
oversee the plumbers i don't think we
need a bureaucracy to oversee the
plumbers i think we are just going to
vote to be like the plumbers are doing a
bad job
so the plumbers you guys have to fix
your [ __ ] or else you're not getting or
whatever
we don't need a bureaucracy we are the
people should rule over the plumbers
because we uh
we are their
their customers
and their bosses
with the internet democracy should be
easier
really him really lying to us about the
raisin bread this whole time i would say
don't like take what william says in a
set too seriously like don't uh get hurt
that he doesn't like pickles or anything
just remember that he's trying to be
funny and uh don't like uh
or don't uh
don't live and die on what what uh what
you know what he's saying on stage i
mean you should enjoy it and have a good
time but uh don't take it so personally
uh but the funny thing is like uh
the funny thing is like if you take it
personally it's funnier but if you take
it too personally then it's not funny so
you just find a good balance of like
whatever what kind of porn do i like i
like tickling porn i like spanking
um
[Music]
and uh you know
seeing a girl's booty
i love
japanese massage porn
um
i love
wrestling porn
i love a lot of porn
william has said he goes into malls and
spray civilians with an ar-15
yeah
he did say that
uh it's mostly for a joke maybe some of
it's for real
um i think that
i think that what percentage of jokes
would you say are true or baselessly in
truth i would say all of it has a basis
in truth um jokes are a tool to express
myself and i want to express the parts
of myself that are true and that i think
people should hear
um
and
things that i find funny and what i
think is
funny and what how i find things funny
so it's all like whatever
[Music]
i think that
[Music]
jokes are a tool and they are an
expression and they show you a part of
what a person is thinking and some
people don't like what some people are
thinking and that's
understandable because we're coming from
a time when we were thinking horribly
incorrect things like about gay people
and black people and marijuana
and we have a lot of old baggage in our
heads our cultural
uh you know
baggage from our culture that was uh
trying to
tell us about how things should be or
whatever
um so i think that uh
a lot of what we think is like old
school brainwashing that we need to
exercise and
get rid of and i think that we need to
uh
hold
uh people accountable to uh
think the
think the right things or think
correctly or
have the right
mentality or
[Music]
to
to have intellectual rigor and not
think stupid thoughts that don't make
any sense but to
but to make uh intelligent thoughts and
intelligent whatever's
intelligent ideas
and uh if you're someone's going on
stage and doing stuff that's like dog
whistling for racism or putting the
japanese in internment camps then people
are going to be rightfully horrified by
that
and
maybe like you should be coming from a
place in your soul where you don't want
to put japanese people
in concentration camps
do you think psychedelics have its place
in medicine yes i think psychedelic mind
the mind is a very powerful thing and if
you can correct the mind then you can
correct the body and i think a lot of
people are really weird and
their minds need to be fixed with
psychedelics what is your goal in comedy
my goal
in comedy
is to
express myself very well and to do it at
an hour at a time and to do it all over
the country and to express myself
powerfully in a very good way to in a
very funny way
and to be really good at it and to get
paid
to do it and
go around doing comedy a lot
that's my goal
um
hello garcia
why is philip garcia mentioning me oh
cause we're on a show together
put it up there
phil garcia works up the
vulcan so maybe
i'll ask him who's opening for rogan
tonight
that sounds
nice have
that
i really usually found that when i'm
texting someone if i take out the first
thing that i was going to say that the
text is better like
oh that's cool to hear i already have
all the camera equipment set up like
it's just take out the
let's get to here and then just get
right to the point and make it stronger
and then it'll hit harder hans what do
you think of mexicans i think that they
are very beautiful people they have very
sexually
attractive women
and i think that
their country has been [ __ ] by
american trade and they are unable to
escape from the grasp of america
america doesn't treat its allies very
well
and it's no wonder why countries don't
want to be under
american rule
because
it's not turning out that well for
mexico and it's not a good luck for us
if we want people to
listen to us and uh
you know
do whatever
we should treat our allies better
but we can't
because we want to make a lot of money
um but uh
yeah
if i got the first part of all my texts
it would be let's [ __ ]
it's great you should text that to
people
like her bonnie
[Music]
okay then why do you hate americans
um
why do i hate americans because
they're selfish and only think about
themselves and are not willing to
sacrifice anything for the greater good
but i also do love americans because
they are very opinionated they're strong
individuals they actually like utilize
their individuality to make an
interesting life instead of just doing
whatever the group wants them to do the
best way to make a good group is to have
a lot of great individuals and i think
americans are great individuals i just
wish
uh
that we could harness that and not have
them destroy the rainforest
but uh how do i know if i would make a
good comic
um if you have if you like ideas and all
that
i love channel five
any recent documentaries um i don't know
vince k
seriously this is one of my favorite
jokes i'm giving it to
use
is satan your daddy
do you know who tiny taxi is she is from
texas thank you later i don't really
like midgets that much
um
i'm
trying to see if this lady wants to [ __ ]
um
how do i know if i'd make a good comic
who's worth for hound scam
it's like a joke i don't know what
you're talking about i think i missed
the text
um
austin restaurants golden tigers really
good
favorite member of sonia
and twice um
the main one is
and twice i don't really know
they're all hot though they all look the
same they are the same body type
uh
kim drops says she's a real kim
um
there's a thousand dicks on the wall how
many are you gonna choke on
i hate those jokes
there's a thousand dicks on the wall how
many are you gonna choke from
i mean the setup is already so
incendiary
am i on this today
starts at 8
round rock
oh nice okay so i'm on a show tomorrow
i should write this down in my calendar
uh which is great because
i am not getting booked on the rogan
shows unless i am
for
tomorrow which would suck because i have
today off and now i have two shows
tomorrow potentially but probably only
one
99 corona is more like 99 strains isn't
our sequel to schindler's list
oh [ __ ]
i feel like called
oh yeah
i'm trying to move here as little as
possible i want everyone to meet me here
and hopefully they'll do it
uh
kim drops how was your name kim and
you're not a woman how did you meet joe
end up opening for him the way i met joe
is uh i was on kill tony
i was on kill tony and um
i ended up having sex with this girl in
his broom closet and then greg
fitzsimmons saw that happen i saw the
after effects of that
um
and then he went on to the rogan podcast
and told rogan about it and on that day
rogan
called up uh
uh
rogan asked tony to ask me to open for
him so me getting laid in a broom closet
was the crazy energy
uh that rogan was like man i gotta i
gotta see what this guy's all about and
then i ended up opening for rogan for
him that day
uh so then
the story whatever whatever
the story is uh that's the story and the
the rest is history that's what i was
trying to say i'm not high i'm not tired
my eyes are open
bj
simmons is a man kim is a unisex name
maybe has a last name but as a first
name you're a dude named kim
that's kind of worrying
yo kim
my man kim over here
once your choice drink whiskey coke it's
just easy simple
have you ever gone into a fight with
another comic
uh
yeah
physically
no i don't think i've gotten into a
physical fight
besides inside the training dojo
of my brazilian jiu jitsu master
um
in a while because i got my [ __ ]
together and i can handle my emotions
without [ __ ] going crazy
the name kim is ill song
what if the name kim is a song and
someone's singing it badly so you're
like the name kim is ill song
we can tell you haven't been in a
physical fight oh
yeah
that's a good thing you don't want to
get in a lot of physical fights
if you take pride in getting into
physical fights that's pathetic
um
uh i enjoy physical fights as much as
the next guy but i enjoy
not being hurt a lot more
it's pretty dope
um
i am looking to get a gun i think that
i'll get a texas license so i can
get it
um
all right i think i'm going to end it
here so